what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
foreseeable future
okay so when I crossed 900,000
subscribers I said we were gonna do a
giveaway so we're gonna do a 900,000 sub
giveaway and I know I haven't done it
yet the reason why is because I've been
trying to find a way to do it in a way
that's the fairest of people what I
thought about doing was setting up an
email address and saying like the first
30 people who respond to that will get a
trade the problem is what if you're one
of those people who don't watch my video
until like you get off work or you're
somebody who's busy all day or you catch
up on the weekends it's not fair to
those guys so here's what we gonna do
there is an email address down in the
description alright send an email only
send me one if I see you send me more
than one email I'm just going to ignore
you I'm not even gonna take you into
account send me one email all right do
not put anything in the description
alright in the subject of that email
just type in the word giveaway and then
tell me what trade you want one trait
from all-new all-different marvel or DC
rebirth only gonna do one trade the
reason why is because if I start doing
like two or three trades per person over
the course of the entire month of April
that's gonna rack up really fast what
we're gonna do is for the entire month
for the next 30 days 31 days whatever it
is I'm gonna give away 1 trade each day
now here's the kicker I'm going to
Wrestlemania this weekend so I won't
actually buy them as from the mat until
I get back which is like the third of
the 4th or something like that but maybe
it's the fitness excitement on my head
but regardless we're gonna give away one
trade each day over the course of the
month and I will select the winners when
those those things start to come out you
know I'll let you guys know or you'll
get your thing you know you'll get your
thing in the mail or whatever it is but
the idea here is I just want to do a
giveaway in the most amicable way
possible in the fairest way possible
anyway getting into it we are back into
our whole thing on on how to kill
superheroes the problem with this is
that we are getting ridiculous every
week at our how to kill superhero series
we've been tackling more and more
powerful characters we've tackled
characters that are nearly impossible to
kill we've tackled characters that are
immortal in fact we have tackled
characters that are technically already
dead I don't know how we did Solomon
Grundy we did we did a body skin of our
teeth but we really had to like dig down
to make it happen but today I believe
that we've finally taken the plunge over
the edge of sanity and reason and we're
finally in the territory of completely
insane and the reason why I say that is
today we're not simply trying to kill a
character with an extreme amount of
durability or a character who can
regenerate or even a character that can
resurrect this
nope today we're going to try to see if
we can kill the supreme beauty of the
Marvel Universe the one above all now I
have done a full explanation on the one
above all in the past where I basically
go through anything that you could ever
want to know about the character so if
you want a more in-depth analysis about
you know the one above all you know I'm
not gonna say the one above all over the
course of this whole thing we're gonna
call him Jim so if you want to know more
about Jim then go ahead and check out
that video down in the description but
for everyone else I'm going to briefly
run through the character who he is and
what we know about it so as far as we
know Jim is responsible for the creation
of the Marvel multiverse as with all
life with it basically I mean he's more
powerful than any of the cosmic entities
in the Marvel Universe including the
Living Tribunal the beyonders the
Celestials death and eternity
Jim is as far as we know literally
omnipotent that means that his power
level is without any limitations
whatsoever Jim is Opie as hell
pretty much there's nothing that he
cannot do at least we think so anyway
and the reason why I added this caveat
is because there have been so few
appearances of Jim all throughout the
history of Marvel Comics that there are
not a lot of feats that we can observe
to back up the claim that he really is
absolutely and completely omnipotent but
it's by the fact that he only has a
handful of appearances there are a few
things that we do know about the one
above all we know that he is the only
one in the multiverse who's superior in
power to the Living Tribunal a being
that's responsible for maintaining
balance regarding magical forces in the
universe and passing judgment on those
who threatened to upset that Baus now
one thing that I want to lay out here in
Marvel Comics when it comes to managing
the multiverse this is done in two ways
there's cosmic forces magic different
things like that super powerful beings
that's the Living Tribunal and then
there are there's really just like the
evolution of universes making sure that
they all follow a normal line meaning
that mutants emerge around the same time
super-powered beings were emerged around
the same time that the various versions
of Stephen strange developed their power
to become sorcerer Supremes around the
same time that is carried out by a group
called the omniversal Development Corp
they serve no other purpose than making
sure that universes evolve the way that
they're supposed to that nothing hampers
that evolution if something does
hamper the evolution and that evolution
can I guess that hampering cannot be
stopped then the omniversal Development
Court will obliterate that universe such
was the case in earth two three eight
when madam Jasper's went crazy developed
an insane amount of abilities like
reality-warping with his mutant powers
created the fury which killed everybody
that had super powers and then they
tried to fix everything and then the JAF
- was what happened I've got a video on
magic Jasper's you guys can go check it
out but we know that according to a
conversation that a walk to the watcher
has with Susan storm and Fantastic Four
number 72 that Jim is the only being in
the multiverse that's truly all-powerful
furthermore we also know that the cosmic
entity known as eternity tells Doctor
Strange and his own solo series with
issue number 13 that the one above all
is more powerful than himself as well as
his sister death and that he rules all
realities now in Thor anyone number 14
Thor states that he's unable to conceive
of the one above all power calls from
the creator of all universes and states
that Jim's power dwarfs that of Odin now
another thing that I need to address
before someone admits that I left this
out is that some believe that the one
above all actually appeared in Fantastic
Four number 511 under the writing of
Mark Waid when Reed Richards Susan storm
and Johnny Storm all ventured a heaven
where they encountered the recently
deceased Ben Grimm now the four of them
later meet a being that's referred to
alternatively as God the maker and the
Almighty that takes on the form of
legendary Marvel artist Jack Kirby now
Kirby's States to the team that he has a
collaborator suggesting that the god of
the Marvel Universe is actually made up
of both Stan Lee and Jack Kirby as two
sides of the same coin later we see
Kirby repair Reid's disfigured face as
well as restoring Ben Grimm to life
however although the one above all is
commonly referred to as God of the
Marvel Universe it's not actually 100%
certain that the version of God that we
see embodied by Jack Kirby and the one
above all are the same entity the reason
I say this is actually found in journey
into mystery number 627 written by Karen
Gillan and published in 2011
seven years after Kirby's appearance in
Fantastic Four in this issue
Mephisto describes a Living Tribunal - a
bartender who asks him if the Living
Tribunal is God
Mephisto replies that he's not and that
if he does no God he's not exactly
chatty about it now this suggests that
maybe the one above all is distinct from
God so
the Living Tribunal has spoken about the
one above all previously so it appears
that he is familiar with the one above
all and does not seem shy about stating
who it is so it's actually unclear
whether or not God and the one about
while are synonymous or if they are in
fact two different entities now with all
that being said we move on to our usual
questions can the one above all be
killed and if so how can it be done well
to answer those questions let's look at
the only time at least the only times I
know of that anyone has ever come close
to rivaling the one above all power in
the history of Marvel's publications
this occurred in a 2003 miniseries known
as marvel the end during this event
Thanos absorbs the power of an object
known as the heart of the universe which
is basically an ancient source of energy
that was discovered out in space
somewhere harnessed by aliens and then
given to an Egyptian pharaoh allowing
him to go forward as a harbinger of
these individual aliens forcing peace on
his section of the universe itself now
after taking on the power of the heart
of the universe
Thanos becomes extremely powerful and I
mean ridiculously powerful so powerful
that the joint efforts of Galactus the
Celestials death infinity eternity and
the Living Tribunal were not nearly
enough to come close to defeating him
now when you consider that the Living
Tribunal is thought to be the strongest
character in the Marvel multiverse with
the exception of the one above all the
fact that Thanos was able to take him
down is pretty impressive and so because
of that with Thanos absorbing the power
of the heart of the universe he was
thought to be equal in power to the one
above all with this in mind it seems
that it might be possible for a being
that is more powerful than Thanos to
absorb the heart of the universe and
actually exceed the one above all in
power and believe it or not is actually
not hard to find a character that could
be more powerful than Thanos even at his
peak and would have the desire to kill
the one above all one possibility would
be the beyonders of race of people that
we saw actually killed a living tribunal
in an attempt to destroy the multiverse
during the lead-up to Jonathan Hickman's
secret wars now if to be honours are
powerful enough to kill the Living
Tribunal at their baseline level should
they be able to take the power of the
heart of the universe the possibility
exists however small it may be but they
could exceed the one above all's power
level and might even be able to kill it
however this plan has a couple of
problems first after Stannis defeats the
team of cosmic entities and Marvel the
end he absorbs the multiverse and
reforms it just as a
was but removes himself from existence
before doing so however Thanos concludes
that he was only able to do this because
the one above all orchestrated the
entire scenario to fix the problem in
the multiverse of superheroes dying and
coming back to life
now even though Thanos became stupidly
powerful it was only because the one
above all allowed him to do so that he
achieved this level of power with that
in mind it's unlikely as the one above
all would allow the beyonders to fuse
with the heart of the universe as he'd
be able to use his omniscience to deduce
their true motives secondly Tom Brevoort
the executive editor and senior vice
president of publishing at Marvel has
gone on record to explicitly state that
Marvel the end is not part of the
official Marvel continuity so as far as
we know the heart of the universe
doesn't even exist in the official
Marvel Universe so it turns out that
this Avenue is not one that's likely to
lead us to success this ultimately brees
us to the crux of the problem I'm going
to be real with you guys here I'm gonna
be real I know I'm gonna get blasted in
the comments for this well hopefully not
but maybe I will but we have to be
honest this may be one of the only times
in the history of our videos on how to
kill superheroes will rerun to the
problem of not being able to kill
someone even though we know almost
nothing about the one above all we do
know that he's repeatedly referred to as
the most powerful entity in Marvel
Comics and we have not seen anything in
an in continuity story that has ever
been presented as a legitimate threat to
the one above all so I think that we
finally met our match I mean we've had a
good run in recent weeks you know cue
the montage music for my editor we've
had a good run in recent weeks and
killing some crazy powerful characters
batman solomon grundy and other
characters that i can't recall off the
top my head but i think that this time
we took on more than we can handle in my
opinion as long as Marvel Comics exists
the one above all will be pulling the
strings in that way I guess you could
say that the only way to really get rid
of him would be to get rid of Marvel
Comics completely meaning you'd have to
stop reading comics stop watching the
movies and TV shows stop by the
merchandise and let Marvel fade into
obscurity but since you've just spent
the last 10 minutes or so watching a
video on how to kill a while
powerful being I don't think there's any
danger of that happening but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come and explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like I mean we all kind
of agree that this is this is probably
the most predictable outcome you know we
just can't kill the one above all we
can't kill just it just doesn't seem
possible we just can't kill the one
above all but we can kill characters
like superboy-prime we can kill
characters like Galactus so if you guys
are interested in seeing videos like
that then leave those characters down in
the comment section let me know what you
guys think do not forget about that
giveaway email down in the description
and I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]